bacon! It is difficult for us to reject the temptation. You know 43% of Canadians.
Will you choose bacon instead of sex? This is the result of a 2014 survey. Then you know
What did Neil Armstrong and Boz Edlin eat on the first meal on the moon?
There is forty-three thousand calories in a single piece of bacon. And here shows the same heat
Apple and broccoli. It's easy to see which ones can easily fill your stomach...
But who will eat only one piece of bacon? Looking at it from another angle, one hundred grams
Apple is about fifty thousand cards, and one hundred grams of bacon is about five hundred and fifty kilocalories. Sixty-eight percent
Calories come from fat, and almost half of them are saturated.
So every American eats an average of nearly 18 pounds a year.
Or eight kilograms of bacon...should not surprise you! This is the amount of 44,000 kcal per year. In the United States alone,
The industry that produces sliced ​​bacon is worth four billion. Even 65 percent of Americans say they support
Bacon became their national dish.
In fact, different countries in the world use different parts of the pig to make bacon.
For example, Canadian bacon is made from pork chops, and British people use pork shoulders and ham.
Americans use pork chop. 11% of a standard weight pig can be used to make
bacon.
So why is bacon so fascinating? When the bacon is heated, the fat melts, sugar and
Amino acids produce unique chemical effects. This chemistry has produced
About one hundred and fifty volatile organic compounds. They float in the air and
Produces a very attractive smell that makes you drool. So this is not just
The snack you want, its smell itself is irritating your head and body
The best example of chemistry.
Bacon is indispensable in our modern culture. Bacon mania is already a sport!
From bacon toothpaste to bacon air fresheners, even... bacon condoms! some people
Never satisfied!
But bacon is not without harm. Four cooked bacon is already you
It is recommended to use half of the daily salt intake, and most of the food such as bacon and luncheon meat
Contains a chemical called sodium nitrite. It keeps the meat red and
Fresh, not naturally gray. It also affects a variety of health issues.
These nitrites chemically interact with amino acids during cooking, producing nitrosamines.
Nitrosamines are carcinogens that increase your risk of cancer. Absorbing a large amount
Sodium nitrite will also weaken your body's red blood cells.
The ability to deliver oxygen. On the other hand, sodium nitrite can prevent the cause
Bacterial growth of botulism.
When you eat pork, remember to control the serving size. It is best to eat some
Antioxidant fruits and vegetables!
Do you feel hungry when you see these bacon? Check out the brand new AsapTHOUGHT for photos of why food
Will stimulate your appetite. There are some delicious science behind it, so please
Click on the screen to see.
Special thanks to audible for supporting this snippet and free at audible.com/asap
Audiobooks. We recommend this week's book by Mark Schatzker - 'The Dorito Effect',
Because we take every opportunity to learn about science and potato chips at the same time.
This is a very interesting book. It is about the relationship between nutrition and taste and how we change food.
You can get it at audible.com/asap or
Lots of other books!
Don't forget to ask us questions and subscribe to the channel for more weekly science videos!